and unassuming 86 year old evangelist is
sharing a message of healing around the
world she has traveled for years to
serve a predominately Muslim countries
to spread the gospel
she says her goal is not to convert but
to educate James Brown travel with her
last month for cbsn on assignment and
learned how her message is received in
the Muslim world JB is with us now from
Washington good morning and good morning
to you Charlie and yes Marilyn Hickey
has visited exactly 136 countries as an
evangelist but she's made it her special
mission to reach out to Muslim countries
like Egypt Sudan and Pakistan to try to
build bridges of peace and understanding
and she invited us on her eighth trip to
Pakistan to the city of Lahore and here
is just a snippet of what we found vicki
has become an unofficial ambassador to
Muslim countries and she's found a
kindred spirit in the grand Imam of
Lahore one of the most powerful
spiritual leaders in Pakistan today he
welcomes her for tea at his home after
tea we head back to the cars to visit
the bath Shahi mosque a Persian
architectural wonder
the grand Imam leads this 344 year old
mosque the oldest in Pakistan his
following at Friday night prayers are an
awesome sight
he took a couple of questions on the
sacred grounds is Marilyn hickeys visit
and what she's establishing created here
as effective or more effective than
politicians man cementing politician the
politician they are coming when the old
programs their own agendas but when it
comes to the religious leader when comes
to the mom so she brings love for the
people of Pakistan so I understand and
I'm convinced as a religious leader that
her love and her Wizard is more
effective than other people
[Music]
good morning JB great to have you here
you're looking still my man very healthy
and well hey I came back from Pakistan
about 10 pounds heavier Charlie because
they expect you to eat wherever you go
what impact and do as the Pakistanis do
absolutely and I'm certainly Margaret
and Vlad both know that all too well
Charlie but you know what Charlie I'm
Marilyn Hickey is extremely effective on
her mission as she says is to cover the
earth with the word or if you will the
gospel and as a late minister and
evangelist Oral Roberts told her don't
let yourself go to the grave with your
mantle or your gift
so she's about spreading the good news
she doesn't use the word convert because
she says that's a dangerous word
Margaret would know that better than me
but her aim is to transform and she's
done an exceptional job and you should
take a look tonight you'll see how
effective she is Pakistan guarantees
freedom of religion but the religion
there is Islam how does that yeah no
question about it 98% Islam but you know
what Charlie there is a spirit of
accommodation or cooperation but to be
clear in Lahore last Easter some 70
Christians were killed by suicide
bombers so we did travel as does she
with a security bubble Charlie JB thanks
so much okay you can watch Davies full
report tonight on a new CBS in on
assignment it airs at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS and our streaming
network CBS in